気づいたら思ったよりベイブレードたくさん買ってました
ギュン　　カッカッカッカッ…
カッ　ボンガラガラ
ホーーー！！！
様々な戦法が 楽しめるようになってきた
遊戯王、じゃねぇ！
ふっ
ベイブレード
結構種類が増えてきて
今後ももっと増えてくんでかなり楽しいです
色んな戦略が広がった今
カスタム力でもない
シュートの打ち方でもない
そう！
回転力。
と言う訳で今回はこういう市販のシューターではなく
こちらの！
キュイィィィィィィィィィィィィン
がらがらがらがら
わっわっ
こちらの高速ドリルを使って、ベイブレードを回していきたいと思います。
いやヤバいからねこれ回転力がホントに笑えないスピード
こうゆう速度から、もう一気にすごい回転しますよ？
ヒュィィィイイイイイ
ギュイィィィィィィィィィ!!
うわああああああああああああ！！！！！！
これヤバいよ。
あの、 ホントに危ないのでやんないで下さい
と言う訳で、今回これを何とか使って、
ベイブレードをﾁｮｯﾄね、最高の、１秒で４２００回転するこの高速ドリルで
ベイブレードを回して、今日僕はベイブレード界最強の男になろうと思います
では、行こう！
まず考えなきゃいけないのは、どうやって回すか、っていう事です
普通になんか、穴が開いてるだけなので、
ここにベイブレードを付けるのはちょっと難しい、と。
となると、どうやって回すかがポイントになってきます
作戦その１
普通に回っているベイブレードに向かって
これを直付けして、このまま
ってやってもう回転しているベイブレード自体のスピードを上げます。
これ結構多分不安定だから難しいと思うんだよね
3 2 1
ゴーシュッ！
落ちt
きたきたきた、OK
逆回転か
じゃ次はもう０からここからスタートしよう
この状態でゆっくりスピードをかけて回す
おっ！
行ける～気はする
あー
うおー
次はちょっと作戦を変えましょう
今なんでダメだったかというと多分
接着してたんすよ、ここが
ここが接着してたから
スピードがめちゃくちゃ速くなったとしても
離すときにちょっとぐらってなっちゃって
そこで減速して結局スピードが出なかったんで
次はガムテープを使います
ガムテープをここの先端に貼って
んで、ここにベイブレードをくっつけると
うん、いい感じいい感じ
んで、回転させると多分
多分スピードが速すぎて自然落下しちゃうんで
自然落下するまでにもうこk・・・
ﾌﾞｯ
自然落下するまでにスピードが上がっていると
そうなれば最高速度で落下できるんで
もうシューターと同じ原理ですね
落ちるまでに回転力を高めてそのまま
放つ
それをちょっと高速ドリルでやってみようと思います
うわーわわわわわ！！
今重心とらえてなかったな
わー！！！！！
うわっ！！
わぁっーーー！！！！
無理ぽ
次はもうちょっと本気です。
接着剤。
接着剤をベイブレードにつけて、ここにくっつけて
ガムテープの何がダメだったかというと
バランスが取れなかったんすよ
だから重心がブレたんでさっきみたいにポロッポロッて
まっすぐ落ちることができなかったのでで、
次は接着剤でちゃんと中心を捉えて
まっすぐ落としたいと思います。
いきます。これでしっかり付けると。
これでしっかり付けます。
完璧です。もう多分、真上をとってるんで、
これでちゃんとくっついて高速回転させて、
速すぎて落下すると
大回転になると思います。
もう来たんじゃない？もう来たんじゃない？
うわ！強いなこれ。これ多分いったよこれ
よし、完璧完璧
これはイタッシャーハシャー（？）
えー？日本語
これはいったでしょう。
もうこれ一発勝負でいきましょう。
いきます！
3 2 1
まった、手袋
これは多分、成功パターンなんで
流石に防具をつけておきます。
ではいきます。
3 2 1
ゴーーーシュート！
あれ？
あ、やべ、取れなくなっちゃった。
えー？ちょっと待って、どうしよう？
あ！アロンアルファー付けたての頃とかにうつとか
つけて、つけてもうほんのすぐ、
ほんのもうすぐ
もうすぐすぐすぐ、もう今ぐらい
今ぐらいでうちましょう。
もう今うっていいと思う
これで多分回るよ
キタッ！
来た来た来た来た、来た!
きたぞきたぞ
あっはい。